techn capital is structurally
anti-natalist um and the the only way to
fix the anti-natalism thing would
probably be to smash techn capitalism
which is a fairly radical proposal and
and it's certainly not one that any
political party is going to stand on in
next year's
election hello and welcome to Marshall
matters with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator today I have the privilege of
speaking with Mary Harrington Mary is a
columnist regular contributor here at
The Spectator a columnist at unheard and
uh spearhead the face of the new
reactionary feminist movement a new type
of feminism and she is author of the
book feminism against progress that came
out earlier this year 2023 a book which
uh goes into or describes a transhuman
cyborg democracy of meat Lego gnosticism
Biol libertarian feminism in a
post-human dystopia running on limic
capitalism heading towards gestational
communism
if that sounds very AR and I hope we can
dig into some of that uh to um people
who haven't heard of those terms and if
we don't get into it we will Infuse you
so that you will go and get this book
and I know you will enjoy it as much as
I did but uh uh so Mary thank you for
coming in and speaking with me thanks
for having me um so before we go into
all of that uh some some of the things I
described there I wondered if you could
take me
a little bit on your journey and being
the face of a new type of feminism which
to me seems almost like a conservative
feminism um but we can speak about that
if that triggers you um uh but I learned
in your book uh that you've been on
quite a journey uh seemingly through
various ways of feminism and
postmodernism and even for a period uh
assing your feminine identity and
identifying as a Sebastian or Sebastian
and I to me learning that seemed given
away you are now quite uh surprising and
I wondered if you could take me on that
Journey if it if it isn't too personal
for for my sins I've spent my life being
a chronic political
hipster which is and so unavoidably I
ended up being an early adopter of what
I suppose is now woke which I mean was a
little bit different in the naughties um
but I was fully fully signed up to most
of the stuff which is now on on its way
to being institutionalized as the kind
of um
hegemonic Progressive in mainstream
ideology you know the the the gender is
a social construct that all of us can
can perform our ourselves sort of as it
were into reality that um hierarchies
should be abolished that um yeah but I
mean the the the whole the whole
Progressive thing was was already there
in in germinal form as a kind of avant
guard ideology in the nties and has only
sort of you know concretized itself into
into its current apparently hegemonic
form since then and I was I was fully
signed up to all of that stuff I was a
radical leftist you know I lived in
lived in communes type communities and
went on anti- capitalist protests and
DED my cut my hair in strange and dyed
it in strange colors and you know
organized weird art events and all that
all that stuff you know and yes I did
change my name to Sebastian for a while
I didn't I didn't stick as it I mean we
can we can get into all of this I did I
found I I didn't like it I didn't like
it because it being a man or being well
I wasn't a man I never I never
identified as a man you didn't like
Sebastian no I changed my name to
Sebastian mostly as a thought experiment
I wanted to see what it was like um to
be addressed by people as something
which wasn't my given name that I'd
grown up with and it turned out in in in
the event that I found it it felt like
too much of an Ask of people who'd known
me my whole life um to to demand of them
that they call me by a name which wasn't
the name which we' which was part of our
shared um experience it just it felt it
felt wrong to ask that to me um whereas
you know if you were to meet some if I
were to meet someone for the first time
and turn introduce myself as Sebastian
people would mostly just completely take
it at face value and address me as
Sebastian because I why not but his
prerogative choice to choose a male name
um yeah I mean I at the time I was sort
of I was hanging out in again you know
all sorts of all sorts of things which
are now mainstream and quite honic were
were already there in German form in the
ughs and one of them was the the quote
unquote gender movement which was very
very very small and very Avant guard and
in its in its London form was basically
one Pub Knight and one message board and
that was just it I mean it's it's sort
of eaten everything seemingly now but
back then that that wasn't really how it
was um it was this this one one baright
in a sort of SD venue on just north of
King's cross it was mostly frequented by
what what I believe were now supposed to
call assigned female at Birth trans
people but I mean this essentially Butch
lesbians who who wanted to you know who
were ambivalent about being women okay
um and you know all pretty much all of
which have sub you know the ones I'm
still in touch with or in any kind of
contact with at all pretty much pretty
much all of them have now trans have
have since transitioned go by he him and
have had various medical interventions
you much every every Les every every
Butch lesbian who I ever dated from that
era has since has since transitioned for
a while and and it was actually this
which started me wondering about the
whole thing sorry we're coming at the
whole um how did you get to where you
are thing from from a very kind not not
the angle I was expecting but actually
this was one of the things that made me
start to wonder about where this was all
going CU I mean when I realized that
pretty much every lesbian I'd ever dated
had subsequently transitioned for a
while I was sort of scratching my head
thinking was it something I said was is
is it me and I realized it isn't it's it
wasn't there's nothing to do with me it
wasn't about me at all um it was very
straightforwardly just that they' done
it because they could um and this was
this was now a thing and and from that I
began to realize that the butch lesbians
were just disappearing they're left
right and Center they were they were you
know all all all and and I mean I I
think I think bu lesbians are beautiful
you know I can also understand why this
that's a difficult cultural space to
inhabit if you're a masculine presenting
woman you know there are there are
hostilities and challenges that you face
on an everyday basis that make life more
difficult right because that's just not
what people expect from somebody who's
female bodied um so in a sense I don't I
don't blame any of those women for
taking advantage of medical Technologies
and discourses which were making it
easier to to just not really not show up
as something weird or unusual in the
world I don't I don't blame them and and
this or at least this is this was my
sort of thought process when I started
when I started noticing that that trans
was becoming a thing and that it was it
was claiming Butch lesbian after Butch
lesbian after Butch lesbian pretty much
my entire the the entire circle of of
people whom I had known as women in that
way were just disappearing and becoming
men so why did you then choose a
different path you say that all they all
all of them disappeared but you have G
well I mean lots of things sort of I
mean I I was my 20s were fairly chaotic
right you know I I I never I never
managed to hold down a job for more than
sort of six months at a time I was
fairly Bonkers on a number of different
axes um for for complicated reasons but
I just was um I didn't I didn't
like yeah I was I was I was not not
comfortable with order I was not
comfortable with hierarchy I was not
comfortable with taking instruction I
was just very cha I mean and this
obviously makes somebody fairly
unemployable from a sort of Normy
perspective so so a disagreeable
contrarian what it sounds like um was I
was I I don't think I was I wasn't
contrarian really I was just nuts um I
was just interested in stuff which was a
long way out of the mainstream you know
I was reading reading alist Crowley and
Judith Butler and um experimenting with
chaos magic and wanting to go to Burning
Man and creating art installations and
um just just not so just except just my
my interests were just a long way out of
the mainstream main but this stuff was
in universities not Burnie M but but
Judith Butler and and that was part of
you know feminist education right right
but but in terms of in terms of people
who are actually trying to put that into
practice in the real world it's pretty
fringe okay right I mean it's it wasn't
it wasn't the sort of it wasn't the kind
of cultural Juggernaut it is now you I
mean if you'd if You' presented your if
you'd announced in a sort of average
normi you know a averagely progressive
group of London artwor people for
example that you you you you wanted to
self-create as a non-binary person they'
they'd probably have raised an eyebrow
and just kind of shrugged and gone along
with it you know you wouldn't you
certainly wouldn't have been able to
mobilize any of the institutional and
sort of punity coercive structures which
are now available to to to underpin
those kinds of identities I mean that's
all that's all very much emerged since
as these things have become more
normalized but but that wasn't really
there so in a I mean I I enjoyed playing
with those kinds of experiments because
it felt like it felt like very un
unconquered cultural un under occupied
cultural space and I was really
interested in this idea of of just is
this I was very interested in the idea
that what you believe is what is and I
really wanted to push the boundary I
wanted to see how far you could go with
that what do you mean what you believe
exactly I was interested in I mean this
this is just underline underline how how
sort of Arcane my interests were at that
point I was I was
I'm going we're going to end up going
down
a such a such a rabbit hop
um no that's that's that's too much for
okay well let me ask then but but but
just take it take I was interested in
the idea that that what you believe is
what is you know the the the edges of
you know where does where does material
reality outside my my perception of it
stop and start and to what extent what
to what extent does what I believe about
the world affect what the world actually
is and to what extent does what people
believe do what people believe
collectively about the world affect how
the world is I was that that was that
was the the main the my main
preoccupation or one of my main
preoccupations in my 20s I mean
obviously that's just not not a
preoccupation that's very compatible
with I don't know going and getting a
job in a management
consultancy or writing readable novels
or really doing anything very very
normal or sayane at all so and and
anyway long story short I got of got
towards the end of my 20s you know the
having conducted a thousand one
different kinds of experiment and in
countercultural ways of living you know
all of which I suppose were ordered to
this um desire to find what the limits
of consensus reality were and came I
suppose to the conclusion that none of
it was very happy and life seemed I
don't know like when you're when you're
22 right life feels as though it's going
to go on forever and you're always going
to be 22 I mean you you you know oh yeah
what I mean a little bit and then you
get you get a few years older and you
realize that no actually several several
years have passed and you no longer feel
22 and in fact life is it's going to go
on for a whole lot longer and you know
maybe I ought to think a bit more
concretely about you know what what I
want to happen in the rest of it and and
it's yeah I living living in a living
hand to mouth in a in a sketchy house
chair with lots of people who sort of
with whose members drift in and drift
out in a in a fairly ad hoc way um just
started to feel like something which I
didn't really want to have happening to
me still in 20 years time so I guess I
took evasive action just about but did
you have a OT or like a no not really
not really probably the thing probably
the thing that sort of knocked me off
that course was I founded I co-founded a
startup with some friends and and it
went wrong it was I was a major
contributor to it going wrong just by
being mental um um I was I was a major
contributing factor to it going wrong
and just but the experience of being
basically kicked out of something which
I'd co-funded for being mental um was a
it that that was a fairly major shock to
the system as you can imagine and it
left me as you I mean it's devastating
when you say mental do you mean erratic
or do
you I just
mean what what what do I mean I mean
it's sort of it's hard to describe from
the outside um but I I was just I was
just not very easy to work with um just
let well maybe we should just leave it
at that I was just not very easy to work
with uh you know lots of interesting
insights and know creative interesting
insights often perceptive but just not
very easy to work with MH um and I was
definitely making things worse there
um I mean it's it's like what having
something that you created go wrong
underneath you um is is pretty
devastating um and you know knowing that
it was your you know discovering that it
was your fault and you know I I mean I
lost I lost sort of everything which
which was giving my life meaning at that
point um you know I lost my Social
Circle I lost my best friend I mean my
my best friend and I falling out
spectacularly was basic you know best
friend and co-founder M um we fell out
spectacularly um and B essentially one
or the other of us was going to have to
go and because I was just so annoying to
work with it was I think the the the
consensus you know the from from
everybody was that it was going to have
to be me so so that's a very
disorienting experience that you then
had to rebuild your life it was it was
brutal I had to I had to rebuild my life
absolutely from scratch pretty much um
you know I lost I lost my whole sort of
social media I lost my my sort of
Professional Network pretty much mhm I
lost my Social Circle I lost my friend I
I lost my best friend um and and I was
unemployed you know it was it was
rubbish um it and it was my fault well
you've now rebuilt your life yeah I mean
this is a but like around the same time
just by you know share by luck or divine
intervention or however you want to I I
met the man I'm now married to um and I
guess I guess I rebuilt my life uh in
relation you know I I built my life I re
I I reassembled my life with his help MH
um you know by the time I by the time
I'd reassembled something like a
functioning worldview I was no longer
living in London I was um I was
married um I had a I still still didn't
and I was retraining as a
psychotherapist I just decided at that
point that I was I was just going to do
something completely different so I I
did a I did a part-time Psychotherapy
training course um which I think I was I
I did that for about I think it was
about 5 years in the end it took um so
I'm actually a qualified psychotherapist
um in hindsight you know the the benefit
that I gained from that was probably um
five five years of Fairly intensive
therapy plus the kind of plus the kind
of interpersonal interactions that and
feedback that you come that that come
with doing that kind of a training and
the upshot of all of which is that I'm
now marginally less difficult to work
with um so that was all you know in a in
a roundabout way that was all very
beneficial
um but by the end of you know by the
time I'd sort of come come come back to
some fairly sort of functioning
integrated sense of myself again I'd
also in the process of doing all of that
pretty much interrogated all of the
values that that had that had fed into
all of the ideologies which had fed into
me just being that person not just
interrogated lived them Tak them to
their full full extent and I came I came
to the I came to the conclusion that a
lot of the the sort of anti anti-h
hierarchical anti
anti-authoritarian um queer Theory
inflected stuff do we call that fourth
wave feminism or is that sort of third
fourth or is that maybe we shouldn't get
into the technicalities of it I I don't
know I mean I yeah but you're a fierce
critique now of that and you're you you
you're equipped like no one else to
critique it because you have lived it
and uh so that perhaps it's been very
important part to where you are now yeah
I mean I was I think the
what people generally describe as the
fourth wave just on a technical Point
what people generally refer to as the
fourth wave is the kind of sex positive
stuff that you get from from the
naughties onwards okay so that's you
know things like the slot walk and the
slot walk yeah
demonstrations they they are they're
sort of public rallies if you like or
protests or demonstrations where women
will strip down to very very little
clothing and much in Def in in defense
of of being able to dress as you please
without being sexually assaulted in
public that sounds terribly exciting
I've I've never been one them happen
this is a I mean and and that and sort
of associated um feminist arguments in
favor of sex radical sexual Liberation
radical sexual self-expression um you
know Fe and and embracing embracing all
sorts of um I suppose you you diverse
sexual behaviors you might say know
polyamory or BDSM or you name it um and
and saying this is all this is all good
and fine and actually what we need to
talk about is consent and um empowerment
and
and that's that I mean it's a very
that's a very crude and slightly
reductive characterization of the fourth
wave but that's that's broadly it and
that's that and then all the way up to
the sort of 2017 onwards me too thing
uhuh um that yeah I think that's that
that's what people generally refer to as
the fourth wave and that that sort of
that pretty much passed me by because by
that point you know by the time all of
that started happening I was married so
I was MH and and well into my well into
my long dark tea time of the Soul right
you reading reading countercultural
blogs and trying to trying to rethink
what I a mom's blogger by that point as
you describ you were a mom's blogger by
that point as you described before we
started talking not so much I mean I was
I was an avid mums Netter for a while um
which probably also contributed to not
anymore uh I just don't have time
anymore I think I think you can only be
you can only be committedly addicted to
one social media platform at a time and
that that's just that's just more
Twitter at the moment okay what happens
to I don't actually know mom's net I've
not been on Mom's net what's going on on
Mom's net is it still an important it's
a it's a parenting discussion forum you
know a lot of it is stuff about your
kids you know there are there are whole
whole for whole sub subsections
dedicated to breastfeeding or um and
does it lead politically some way or is
it um historically it leans left
liberal um but it's it has it has in it
has interesting characteristics in that
way because it's not um it's it's not
it's not aggressive aggressively woke or
at least or rather it's it it leans left
liberal but it but it but it's also um a
hot bed of turism and has been for a
long time you know for Fairly obvious
reasons you know if you've if you've gen
if you've grown new humans in your
literal entrails you're just less likely
to believe that humans can literally
change sex because you just know that's
nonsense yeah um and also you're likely
to take a protective attitude
to having strange men in a single sex
changing room so so and and because
because the the founders have always
have always been very protect they sort
of classical liberal I suppose in their
approach to free speech and they've
always been very they've always tried to
walk a line between um allowing open
discussion even of um Politically
Incorrect subjects like trans the fact
that trans women are men um and and and
trying trying whilst um coming down
quite hard on just gratuitous ad homm
sort of or or you know
unpleasantly unpleasantly attacking
responses to that so so they've they've
they've allowed that discussion to
happen and because it was happening in a
community of Ms um or sort of you know
it there's a whole there's a whole Forum
on momet dedicated to feminism and
women's rights um inevit I mean it's a
community of women of course there is um
which
is
May which hosts a lot of a lot of
England's radical feminists you know
which which might be a minority but you
know no I mean mset has played a very
interesting cultural social and cultural
role I mean just zooming back from that
a little one of the things which I think
is interesting and which the larger
structural level I think has played into
um where we found where we find
ourselves today you know thinking about
talking and thinking about you know what
what I slightly jokingly call
reactionary feminism I actually think
the digital revolution has played a huge
part in that because it's it's it's
created a discursive field in which
women busy women who are mothers are
able to have a voice by that I mean if
you there was a there's a classic
article from from a feminist magazine in
the 80s that I I read a little while ago
that that grumbled about the fact there
was a women's there was a women's center
a feminist run Women's Center that held
a vote about whether or not they should
include a child care facility there and
the and the proposal was voted down
because none of the feminists who were
mother s were able to be there because
they were looking after their kids right
so there's a there's a there's a
structural material reason why um women
who are mothers have often found
themselves not exactly excluded from the
from feminist conversations but
certainly at the periphery because
they're just busy they just doing stuff
yeah busy um and what's what's
interesting about the digital Revolution
for all that I'm critical of it in a
great many ways and I think it has a lot
of negative um side effects is that you
know every
every mom has a smartphone pretty much
um and and the fact the fact that you
can be you can have half you can be
scrolling while pushing a buggy you know
is at the at the risk of sort of
stereotyping in a slightly n way but but
you can you can have a voice in feminist
conversations while simultaneously
wrangling three small children and that
that that just wasn't physically
possible prior to the digital prior to
the social media Revolution and I think
this is having this is this is visibly
having a really interesting effect on on
feminism um because it it brings
motherhood back into the picture because
clearly you know a lot of the a lot of a
lot of the your feminists tended to skew
either to two women who could Outsource
their child care or two women who just
didn't didn't have um didn't prioritize
caring responsibilities so the ones who
are Outsourcing are the Elite and they
will have Elite ideas University style
ideas and and once you have you know
women who are just regular mothers you
know have an increasing Voice Within
feminism I think that's one of the
reasons why why the the gender movement
has been emerging because if you're a
mother then obviously you think this
stuff is complete nonsense I mean not
you know there are mothers who don't
think it's nonsense but you're more
you're you're more likely to have some
questions yeah right if you've if if you
if you're a mom so on the on the gender
critical uh topic and and this came up I
don't know if you saw uh last week at
Rosen Murphy the singer of Irish singer
of the band formerly of Maloo and uh she
wrote on Facebook or online somewhere
that that puberty Walkers was bad for
gender dysphoric kids and that big
farmer running away of it and and having
come from the music industry this this
is something I'm particularly sensitive
to and her her record label didn't drop
her but they said they're going to um uh
stop promoting her new album uh venue in
London rough trade East cancelled two of
her shows and this continued push back
and this morning I read a guardian piece
by Laura snapes slamming her again um oh
yeah they they reviewed her album didn't
they just couldn't couldn't resist yeah
the music's great but I don't like her
opinions they have to distance
themselves from the opinions as if those
opinions have anything to do with the
album but what what it occurred to me
and sort of zooming out bit is that that
the the the gender or the um trans
debate seems to me to be the sort of
surface level manifestation of the
feminist um the two sort of the progeny
of of maybe postwar feminism and I'm not
educated like you in this so I'll make
some mistakes as I describe this but it
seems to me that there are some there's
one group who put biological sex as the
Salient uh over uh gender and another
that puts gender a Salient over oh we
have a uh I didn't mention that we have
actually a third a second guest and this
is the first podcast I guess with two
guests which is Mary's dog safy um who
is um who's might make several
appearances if we're like uh so I I and
forgive me if this is sort of like a a
basic question but uh do you do you
think that uh that the idea of gender
that's come out of of let's say 70s '
80s feminism has led us to this place
like the the the Battle of of the the
turf wars and gender critical battles is
born from
feminism the answer I mean the answer
answer is always yes and no MH um I mean
feminism is in a hugely rich and fr
often very very fractious argument um so
and I I'm there's no way I'm going to be
able to do it justice because I mean
there are vast sedes of theories that I
haven't read as well so you know I'm
probably only you know six inches ahead
of you on that and there's hu you could
spend spend your life delving into the
theories I mean there are there are
second wave feminist anteed to
contemporary
gender theory yes I mean it's
it I suppose I would be in answering
that question um I I'd be inclined to go
back a little bit and I mean this this
was really the thesis of of my book um
was wanting to wanting to go back a
little bit further than the second wave
to try and understand how we got to
where we got to and and this this was
really prompted by becoming a mother
myself and trying to make sense of why
motherhood and care um were appear to be
so uh so sort of at the fringes of the
conversation about feminism um I mean
as I I was a stay-at home mom for a
while after my daughter was born um
which and and I was I was surprised to
find that actually that was what I
wanted to do and but but when I got
there and I started to see my peers
who'd had babies around the same time as
I did going back to work there was there
was a huge amount of ambivalence there
for a lot of women you know some of I
mean there were there were women who for
whom you know career was obviously a big
priority and but plenty more who who who
had jobs more than careers um and who
had very mixed feelings about returning
to a job that they didn't especially
love um instead of looking after their I
suppose usually about roughly oneyear
old baby um and it left that and and it
it also left me realizing that you know
to be in the position that I was in very
fortunately where where I hadn't you
know my husband asked me do you want to
go back to work cuz at that point I was
working contract so I sort of fell off
the edge of the Working World when um
shortly before our daughter was born
born and and so I didn't really have a
job to go back to and and we were we
were very fortunately in a position
where I had the option you know I could
I could go back to work and I and it got
to it and I thought there isn't really
anything I mean I was rubbish at
everything I ever did professionally and
there was wasn't really anything that I
wanted to go back to enough to want to
be away from her for a whole day at a
time just it just it just didn't make
any sense to me you know and I know that
there are a huge range of circumstances
and there a lot of women who have to do
that and who who just didn't and and and
I'm I met plenty of moms who um who
would bitten who would have bitten
somebody's arm off for the option to
have the option um and for whom there
just wasn't an option they had to go
back to work you know and who who exper
you
know had a period of quite sort of deep
grief um at having having to wave wave
their little one off to a nursery you
know 12 months old was really still a
baby um that's interesting to hear that
because more often than not I think I
hear of the grief of women having to
give up a career and rather than the
mother's perspective of giving up I
don't know why that's filtering through
maybe that's the the news well I mean
this is this is this is partly about
which women have the mic MH um because
it really it's it's very very much the
case that if you I mean if you've
trained for years for a profession that
you love um yeah I mean but beyond a
certain point there's a real there
really is a zero sum conflict between
looking after a baby and having a
highflying professional job that just is
you can't you can't do both of them at
once very easily um and you you have to
you have to compromise on one side or
it's not possible to have it all um not
really um so if you you know if you love
your job and you have to turn things
down or just or just give it up because
you're looking after a baby then you
might love your baby but you're you're
still going to feel like you've lost
something I mean I I have pretty much
the Holy Grail in professional terms in
the sense that I work from home super
flexibly and you know around school
hours and because I'm largely
self-employed I can I can set my own set
my own times or take you know I can I
can take a week off at no notice um if
my daugh needs me to I do and I have the
mic but but I'm I'm very unusual in that
sense and extraordinar privileged and
most most women who have a who have a
career that they love as much as I love
being a writer are not in that
position um and even even I you know I
love my daughters to bits and I I I'm
very fortunate in the position I'm in I
have I have to turn things down
sometimes for family reasons and
sometimes sometimes I wish it wasn't
like that um but but then I but it's but
and this is and this is you know as as
somebody who you know part in part of my
work is trying to advocate for for for
women to be to be in a position to say
no actually I'm coming down on the side
of family and even then there are times
when I find myself just thinking oh I
wish I could do that um you know some
you there are always trade-offs right um
but just to go back to your question
about why it is that women you know why
why it is you hear more about the grief
of giving up a career like the kind of
women who are likely to end up with a
voice in the public conversation are
just much more likely to be women you
know high high achieving successful
women who have interesting and rewarding
careers you know you just don't you know
no nobody interviews the the checkout
cashier at tesos about how she feels
about going back to work after after
having a baby like nobody cares and I'm
sorry but that's you know I I wish they
and the point is I wish they did um
because actually that's a very different
experience this ad advocating for family
and uh I think seems to be a central
tenant of reactionary feminism something
I'm Keen to to to get to get into
particularly in in the sort of global
fertility crash that you know it seems
like we're in serious trouble and and
fewer people getting married few people
having babies um and I quite Keen to get
into that but if you if I may just one
thing that's I I want you to tell me if
I'm a total idiot for thinking this but
it's one thing I've been thinking about
about the gender versus biological sex
discussion it seems to me that gender is
a total myth and that there is
biological sex I don't I don't think I
believe in gender anymore Am I Wrong to
think that it's almost like it's become
s a
scientific it's completely ideological
but it's now considered like it's a
scientific real thing Am I Wrong to
think that is it is it something real
that I'm just not grasping oh you do you
mean you mean gender identity this idea
that people have an innate sense of
their sex sex self which somehow takes
precedence over embodiment exactly no
that's complete wocks that that's not a
thing at least I I don't I don't it it's
a it's an unfalsifiable belief but
that's come from it's it's a belief not
a fact um you know of the same order as
transubstantiation or you know the
Virgin birth um you know and and I
considerably less pro-social
implications in my view and so not at
all based in science and I and I think
it's come from uh feminist thought that
it's evolved from feminist thought Am I
Wrong to think that the answer to that
is quite complicated or at least the
answer I my my my take on that question
is um does do do you want the short
answer or the long answer let's have the
long answer okay um my my thesis in
feminism against progress um is I
borrowed heavily from ivanich who was
vigorously cancelled back in the 1980s
for a book he wrote called gender in
which he really he turns a lot of the a
lot of the sort of received views about
sex and gender on their head to argue
that prior to the modern era um the the
relations between men and women were
characterized by what he calls
vernacular gender in which what men did
what women did was gendered all the way
down um and they and it varied immensely
from place to place but you know in a in
the subsistence life of peasant
communities what men did and what women
did you know would be gendered all the
way down even down to the kinds of words
people use the kind of tools that were
used the behaviors you know the the
places the spaces you're allowed to
occupy the activities you're allowed to
take place the the activities you're
allowed and unisex work was very rare if
not non-existent and so so this is and
and this is what premod society looks
like as in illich's argument and that
and what he says is that with the with
the Industrial Revolution and the the
rise of sort of homoeconomicus if you
like the um the Adam Smith conception of
economic man as a sort of as a as
fundamentally a sort of transacting
atomized individual um ilich argues that
with with that and with the technologies
that give rise to that we enter into
what he calls economic sex which is in
his view not less sexist as the
feminists would have it than the
premodern world but more sex
because it it it address it assumes a
level of parity and equal access to all
all the goods that are available under
the or under the the order of modernity
between the Sexes whilst covertly
structurally disadvantaging women
because you you and and and this this is
really the the point
where the point where it overlaps with
with my personal experience as as a
woman and as a mother because because
what Lish is describing is is true you
know to the extent that you know if to
to be to be a a free transacting
autonomous individual on the liberal
model which really comes into being with
modernity and with the industrial with
industrial civilization um is less
possible if you're a woman but
specifically it's less possible if
you're a mother because you know to the
extent that you have caring
responsibilities you're not atomized and
to the and and if you're a mother um
your caring your your caring
responsibilities are quite visceral and
embodied um I mean you know down down to
you know having you know carrying
carrying a dependent infant inside your
actual body or feeding or feeding a
newborn baby from your physical body you
know these things tie you down in very
concrete ways um and and you can't be an
and you can't be an atomized individual
on the Liberal Liberal template um and
and also sustain those things you just
physically can't and not only that but
if you're a normally attached devoted
mother to a newborn baby you don't want
to mhm um and this was the thing that
really came as a shock to me me I think
pretty much the second article
thereabouts that I ever wrote for
unheard was called how motherhood put an
end to my liberalism and it was about
about exactly that experience that I'd
always believed this idea that to be to
be a feminist meant to to pursue
unencumbered Liberation on the sort of
rousan model um and to free myself from
all of the sort of sex obligations that
came with being having a female body and
then I had a baby and I realized I
didn't want to because because that that
kind of freedom is radically
incompatible with keeping your baby
alive you know if your baby wakes up
screaming at 4 o'clock in the morning
and and needs needs you to get up and
feed her um you can't just say no I
don't want to and roll over and go back
to sleep it's it's not it's not just
that it would be wrong to do it it's
pretty much physically impossible um
because it just it sets something off in
it's it's very difficult to describe
unless you've experienced it but
literally the only time I've ever
damaged a car in you know 25 odd years
of driving was when I had a hungry baby
screaming in the back CU because I just
literally couldn't think um I couldn't
function properly um and when when you
have a newborn baby under Norm unless
something has gone very wrong with the
bond for some comp like due to
postpartum depression or something like
that you know that that that sense of
continuity with your baby is so strong
that this the the trying to map the sort
of Russian idea of unincumbered
liberalism onto it is just it makes no
sense at all yeah and this is this is
fundamentally this was you know here I
am pushing my buggy around the streets
of um small town beder um thinking about
all of this and trying to make sense of
what's just happened to me um in the
context of all the sort of you know the
the women the the feminism and the
political Theory and whatever else that
I've read up to that point and just
thinking none of this computes and why
how how are we ended up here where
there's a sort of mother motherhood
shaped blind spot in in the whole in the
whole body of political thinking which
is meant to be dedicated to advocating
for women's interests how how how do we
end up there it seems like it's deeper
to me than just motherhood shaped uh
blind spot and and this is really Louise
Perry's argument I think um in in her
book the case against SE sexual
Revolution but post war feminism post
1960s it's women have been for forced by
the leading feminists I think to on
every metric in life do it the masculine
way whether it's in the at home or in
the workplace it's not just in mothering
it's it's everything has has been done
on male terms so I think it's broader
than just the the mother I would agree
with that but I'd also start I'd start
further back at least in feminism
against progress I have started I've
started the story a long way before the
second wave because I think actually it
only makes sense if you go back some
distance before the second wave um and
because I I I went down the rabbit hole
and I and I realized fairly quickly that
it's not as like it's not as though
there are no feminists who ever make try
and make the case for motherhood you
know maternal feminism is a thing you
know this it's a Well worked out body of
theory and you know and recurs at at
repeated intervals throughout the
history of femin I'm probably an
instance of it in many respects but
again and again and again that's not the
kind of feminism that wins um and
somehow again and again and again the
the sort of embodied relational maternal
caring aspect of the feminist argument
ends up being memory hold it just keeps
happening and and so you know along with
the question of you know how have we
ended up with this motherhood shaped
blind spot I I came to realize that the
the question is more like how is it that
the how is it that motherhood keeps
being memory hold why why does this keep
happening and and the the answer the the
conclusion I came to on that um is well
no number one the sort of my my sort of
framing conception of of what's going on
here is that you we we should be
thinking
about the women's movement not as not as
sort of evidence of ongoing moral
progress towards some kind of you know
imaginary heaven on Earth but as as a
response to the Industrial Revolution
and this is really where the the the
piece the ivanich piece fits in because
what ivanich talks about and and which I
which which I think is correct I think
it's I think what he what he describes
is accurate is um a transition from
vernacular gender to economic sex with
the with the arrival of
industrialization which actually leaves
women worse off not better off you know
there's this sort of received view that
in in the premodern world obviously you
know you obviously life is better now
for women than it was in the medieval
period um as it was for men but yeah
obviously progress is a thing yes and
obviously therefore life is better now
for women than it and it probably is on
some metrics but I don't really I don't
believe in progress I don't think it's a
thing um you don't believe in progress
no I don't I don't think I don't believe
I don't believe in progress have we
regressed u i don't believe in regress
either I just think things change okay
well actually this so this is but but
but just just to just to complete
complete that mental sentence um yeah so
so so my my my governing thesis for
feminism against progress is that the
women's movement is not evidence of
ongoing moral Improvement it's an effect
of the Industrial Revolution and and
particularly of the fact that with
industrialization work left the home and
it was it was women's work that left the
home before men's work yeah um and that
and and that left women with with some
previous you know some some historically
unprecedented challenges one of which
was how do you how how do you keep your
end up when you're no longer an
economically active member of a
productive household um and and another
of them is if you're working class how
do you how who who looks after your baby
while you go to the factory I mean if
you if you if under the putting out
system or on in a subsistance agrarian
situation you know you could the all the
the the women's work of vernacular
gender was totally compatible with
having little children under foot but
working working in a large dangerous
Factory this is where cottage industry
the term comes from which I learned from
your book yeah yeah yeah that's where
the term cottage industry comes from but
all of this is but you know having
having a toddler is completely
incompatible with you know working in a
factory for 12 hours a day obviously so
so so what do you do um and the and what
what women did you know and how how
women responded to these new challenges
makes up the entirety of first wave
feminism including o over time the the
the demand for for for the vote and and
and what I've I mean it's a very broad
schematic outline because it's the the
the argument of the book uh isn't isn't
just about industrialization but the
very schematically there was s two set
of characteristic responses in within
first wave feminism to what to what
happened and one of them was to try and
make the case for Domesticity and
motherhood on the new sort of Chief
consumer in a private household model
and this was this was largely a boura
thing um and so there's a Hu there's a
huge body of writing in the 19th century
by women who are who who wanting to sort
of big up women's contribution as
mothers and Educators and homemakers and
you know creators of a space of nurture
and respite from economic competition
and you know a space out inside the
market which is a sort of space of
safety where you don't have to be
homoeconomicus
um so so that's that's one
characteristic response which I suppose
you you could call a sort of form of
maternal feminism but feminist
historiographers from the second wave
onwards have tended to dismiss it
dismiss these these writers as sort of
you know fifth columnists for the
patriarchy I'd never heard of them and
actually this is my this is what I mean
by its memory hold the second the second
wave has completely memory hold the
pretty much the entirety of first wave
feminism I mean I'll get to why I have a
theory as to why which why um well but
anyway I mean this this sort of cult of
do you know the the the feminist
Defenders of the of the private domestic
sphere um I've I've characterized as the
feminism of care and then on the other
side for equally legitimate reasons also
um there was there was another body of
women who argued for women's right to
enter the marketplace on the same terms
as men so not to withdraw into the
private sphere of nurture and care but
to but to to participate in public life
what I and this is the feminism of
Freedom yeah and and if you were to look
around you now you would think that the
entirity of the history of feminism is
only the history of feminism and it is
not exactly and this is and this
fundamentally winant is because the
winners write the history books that's
just always the way and if you and
there's a and you can recuperate the the
feminism which lost if you go rumaging
but there there is there is no
definitive history of the feminism which
lost the battle and the battle happened
in the 1960s or rather it and and it was
and my argument in the book is not that
it was an ideological battle but that it
was another tech transition which tipped
the scales between the feminism of
freedom and the feminism of G the pill
and which which in my in my view is
another indust another Industrial
Revolution it's it signals the beginning
of an industrial revolution which is
still ongoing the transhuman revolutions
yes the which is really the point where
we get from the industrialization of the
world to the industrialization of
ourselves let's not jump into that uh
big swimming pool just yet uh but uh I
just want to say again that my favorite
part of the book I think was what I
considered a revisionist history of
feminism going to pre-industrial because
for me I had never considered so many of
those things and and one of the one of
the things that it really changed my
mind on I don't know if it was explicit
or implicit in and I I had sort of
adopted recently or recent years the
idea that and I think of the the the
nuclear family I think it's Viv VI Rami
the current Republican Presidential cand
he he wrote uh the nuclear family is the
best form of governance known to mankind
well that's part of his his Spiel and
I'd accepted that particularly was a few
years ago BLM part of their Manifesto on
their website was against the nuclear
family and I I had really like been
honing in on nuclear family and how
sacred that was and how important that
was politically but way your book
changed my mind on that by doing this
revisionist history of uh of feminism
and family to pre-industrial times was
that it was actually the extended family
and and um you know families left the
countryside moved to cities and left
their families and actually children are
supposed to be raised in within extended
families with grandparents with aunts
and uncles not just their their parents
and and so I bring this up because I
think uh this ties in somewhat with the
you know the motherhood blind spot but I
think there's an extended family blind
spot and and do you think that that um
saf's disagrees to me what do you think
sopie do we need an extended
family um do you think do you think that
that I've interpreted that
fairly it raises a whole lot of further
questions about how you reverse that
trend of social atomization um but but I
think there's a lot of Truth in that
yeah I mean it's it's that there are
there are plenty of studies that show um
mothers are happier in direct proportion
to how well supported they feel MH um
you know you're as assuming you have a
fairly good relationship with your own
mother if you live if if you live in
proximity to your mother or you know to
to grandparents or to other extended
family and and are able to to have that
to have that support um yes Life Is Life
is better and you know industrial
modernity has definitely sort of chipped
away
a great deal of that you know both
ideologically and also in terms of
economic pressures I mean this sort of
basic assumption that humans are just
kind of fungible work units who can be
picked up and put down somewhere else
you know pretty much at the drop of a
hat yeah um OB is obviously incompatible
with with families certainly it's it's
incompatible with having functional
functional support networks yeah of of
the sort which make raising young
children a nice thing rather than uh an
exhausting chore and this has gone into
and you also write about this in the
book uh State the grow of safety
safetyism uh you know the state care for
raising families it's it seems to me
part of the same sort of movement
there's a battle against fem a battle
against family generally
speaking I think that's definit I I
think there's something to that I mean
it's you you see it most sort of pro
cult provocatively in cultural War terms
when when these these you videos surface
as they do periodically where some state
employee or Child Care functionary says
you know we we we have a right to decide
how your children are going to be raised
or you know we have we have a right to
gender transition your your your
12-year-old without telling you or you
know some something and and it sort of
crops up in extreme forms like that but
but but in a sense you're right I mean
what's what's you know when when the
when a school teacher takes over what
ought to be and obviously apparent a
very profound lifechanging um and I I'd
argue just sort of fundamentally wrong
mistaken parenting decision you know
over the over the heads of the parents I
mean what they're doing just sort of
takes what are you referring to that um
I'm a gender transitioning child without
permission without their parents
knowledge um which is you know a topic
of of contentious culture War at the
moment on both sides of the the Prime
Minister Rishi senuk I think just as a
story yesterday that he was not going
to forbid that in school that the gender
transitioning so that's right I mean
it's a sort of ongoing ongoing Row in
Westminster about you know how how if at
all the government has has any right to
legislate on whether or not um and and
really what and what's going on you know
this this that's really the the the the
most contentious contemporary um fault
line in terms of where where third
parties should or can can or or where
where it's appropriate for third parties
to take over parenting respons
posibilities from Individual families
but I mean if you if you follow that if
you if you go down the rabbit hole a bit
there's a
you how you I mean to you you think
about the number of what what are
essentially parenting decisions which
are outsourced in the course of of
handing over your child to a
nursery
um you know if I were to AR if I were to
take a devil's advocate position I
suppose I might say well why those what
why why why why is this off limits and
not that
um and yes you know to in in defense you
know I've I've used third- party child
care you know we it's it's pretty much
an inevitability unless you're you know
even when I was a stay-at-home mom you
know we used a child minder for for you
know half a day a couple times a week
when when when she was little for a sort
of different reasons um and on on the
whole you know I I don't I'm I'm not
anti- third party childcare um and I'm
certainly I would certainly never um
want anybody to think that I was I was
criticizing or denouncing parents who
find themselves in the position of you
know economically you like you have to
work um and and so you have to hand your
kid over to a nursery you have you like
there are plenty of mothers who you know
families who are ambivalent enough about
that to begin with they don't really
need me having a go at them on top of it
so you know Ju Just to make that
absolutely crystal clear but
um you're also handing over the your the
the of your child to to somebody who
isn't you to somebody who isn't your
family um so with the mother blind spot
and the extended family blind spot as
I've described in mind what I wanted to
ask you was what political policy would
help and and sorry just for further
background you've written as well about
the um the fertil birth fertility crash
which is a global phenomenon in Britain
and this is something I talked about
with Louise Perry when she came in was
um
the fewer women are having babies in
Britain I think this according to on
statistics statistically if a woman is
childless at 30 is a something like a
50% chance she won't ever have a baby
which is a shocking statistic it's not
to say that it's set in stone but that's
just statistically how it plays out with
that as a as a backdrop what can
government do to support mothers support
families encourage them and uh what
would you like I mean we've got an
election next year this seems like
important issues what would you like the
parties the major parties saying for
families I mean fundamentally I don't
think any government policy is going to
reverse the fertility crash I'm
completely Doomer on that I think it's a
spiritual problem before it's an
economic one um and and there is I mean
you know don't I might be wrong you know
let let's give let's give hungary's pro-
family policies a decade and see see if
see if the the cultural change beds in
but even even Victor Orban who's G who's
been aggressively Pro family and very
expensively Prof family in in um in ter
in terms of the that country's policies
um it's seen some uptick in the
fertility rate but it's it's very it's
very small compared you know fundament
fundamentally the issue is a is a
spiritual one it's a cultural one it's
not um and I I would I'd be hesitant to
try and diagnose it certainly in a you
know what what's at the root of that
spirit
crisis um I don't I don't think that's
something which can be summed up
succinctly um but it's but but it but
it's fun I mean the I suppose the the
the the only sort of succinct
formulation I might want to give to that
is is is to say that techn capital is
structurally
anti-natalist um and the the only way to
fix the anti-natalism thing would
probably be to smash techn capitalism um
which is a fairly radical proposal and
and it's certainly not one that any
political party is going to stand on in
next year's election um so that so
that's the you know Ju Just just kind of
you know channeling my Bonkers 20
something let's keep going down the
Bonkers Rabbit Hole what would you
replace techn capitalism
with I mean that that's social
conservatism no no no social
conservatism is just a a slightly
different inflection of Technic Capital
you no the the end of techn cap techn
capital looks like the end of Western
civilization and technological
civilization and you know the Glo
globalized economy and you know it it
probably look it's it would be a
complete nightmare it would be
horrendous um you know and and so we
can't go that way but probably well I
mean you're a doom you're a doom say
about this current trajectory it might
be it might be that we're just going to
end up going that way anyway I mean if
the greter thunberg crew are right then
you know we're we're we're just heading
that way anyway I mean they might be
they might you know well I guess we're
going to find we're going to find out
we're going to find out um but you know
if we if if climate change is real if we
we really are running out of resources
if the EC modernists are wrong we can't
actually find a way of of uncoupling
growth from energy through but if if if
if if you know there's there's a lot of
these are all very contested political
questions um and if we can't fix the
fertility crisis um the the future will
belong to people who can who figured out
how to unplug from the Skinner machine
and furthermore have figured out how to
how to survive and to to to reproduce
themselves um in in the aftermath of
what's going to be the mother of all
comedowns economically culturally
materially socially um you know and I
don't know if know if if it's just going
to be everything getting slowly more
rubbish I don't know what that scenario
would look like you know everything
might just get slowly more rubbish over
the course of 100 years or it might all
just you know implode in some more
spectacular way or or maybe I'm wrong
and maybe maybe the Ecom modernists are
right and and we'll all be fine somehow
so you don't think there's an answer to
my question about whether there's
political policy well I mean there are
things there are there are things we
could do to make things less obviously
anti- family I mean there
are a it would be a start
to one a good a useful starting question
would be um asking whether there are
ways that families could be supported to
care for their own children um instead
of in instead of being being told that
it's obviously liberatory for for women
to be to be separated from their babies
so they can which is fine which is great
and you're probably grateful for the 30
funded hours if you're if you have a if
you have a job that you enjoy but you
know if if you're if you're 30 funded
hours are being used to put packets
through a scanner um maybe maybe you'd
appreciate the being an option to look
after your own toddler um without
without having to without getting your
house repossessed you know th those
those kinds of policies I think and I
it's an endless source of frustration
for me that somehow neither side of the
political Spectrum ever seems to
contemplate the possibility that some
women might enjoy looking after their
own children I mean there's the the
stay-at-home mom tax is you know the
marginal tax on single earner families
is BR MH and I and I just think that's
mad you know children are you know the
data show again and again and again that
children are best are most happiest and
most well adjusted except in you know
outlier situations of you know family
chaos or impoverishment you know
children children flourish best you know
either in the care of their own mother
or father or of another extended family
member you know why why is it beyond the
wit of man or why is it beyond the wit
of politician I suppose I should say to
to to look at policies which could which
could support more more children growing
up in that environment I don't know but
somehow Somehow Here we still are it
doesn't seem to matter how often people
point it out it just never never gets
through that's a it's an endless source
of frustration so I probably agree with
you that it is a cultural issue and and
um you mentioned and at the beginning of
this conversation I I I read off some of
the the phenomena which you describe as
Ki religious in your book let's say
transhuman cyborg democracy meet Lego
nosism cyborg theocracy theocracy excuse
me there's nothing Democratic
about um Biol libertarian feminism uh uh
these are uh quasi religious and and it
struck me reading it that they were and
and actually post-humanism which is a
pseudo religion as far as I can work out
it has its own ethics it doesn't have a
it's you know it's atheistic but so it
doesn't have a metaphysic but it it has
leaps of Faith like any other religion
and uh it seems to me that they are
filling the gaps in the same way that
wokers is filling gaps is the death of
God and these new things uh these new uh
pseudo religions coming in and and
filling the Gap what I wondered was
whether you uh
saw you never go to the religious in
your book but whether one of those
you're so close you the the the feminism
you expound is is very close to
traditional
Christian Christian Christian culture
Christianity is is that the is you know
has all of this stuff not emerged by the
death of
God I would probably argue rather that
um a lot of a lot of the contests that
we're seeing at the moment are are a
continuation of Christianity but you
know the arguments are a continuation of
of the Reformation by other means um you
know what do you mean uh I I think we're
in the throws of a new Reformation I
mean that's that's a big claim and
that's probably the next book
if I ever get myself together to write
the proposal that's probably the next
book the new Reformation which
is largely driven by the end of print
culture and the entry into the
transhumanist era um and and a lot of
yeah I'm let's not go down that rabbit
hole for now but it's it's my yeah a lot
of a lot of the PRI a lot of the sort of
accepted priors of the of the Christian
era are being are being refactored in
the light of Science and Technology um
and those those who those who
uncritically endorse these new
developments as a positive thing you
know sort of white have devised for
themselves a kind of wh labeled version
of um some Christian ethics but Sha of
any of the difficult bits um under under
kind of using so you think those those
are Christian well I mean a lot of a lot
of it has recognizably Christian
overtones doesn't it you know the the
the the hyperfixation on victims um is
is is the it's the crucifixion just
without the without the resurrection or
Redemption
um I'm not sure I buy that because I see
the crucifixion as as that's you know
the message of bearing your cross
honorably is the opposite of victim it's
it's it's to not be a victim despite all
the hell that that life I couldn't agree
more I couldn't agree more and and you
know it would it's not you could say
that there's something quite satanic
about the idea of a a sacrificial of of
elevating a sacrificial victim who
doesn't have any with without without
there ever being a possibility of
redemption um n nonetheless you know
this the motif of of the the the
Sanctified victim um comes straight you
know has has transitioned straight from
from Christian Theology and sort of
broadly Christian culture to to becoming
becoming something else and you know
having having been shown of its uh it's
the it's obvious theological trappings
and the idea that there's a there's an
afterlife or any of that and and and but
but it's alive and kicking just in a
purely materialistic way yeah I
certainly see that with work so so there
that I mean there are plenty of there
are plenty of other examples as well
uhhuh um I mean I sort of the my the the
phrase I coined that people lob back at
me a lot is meet Lego nosism yeah um
this which is is my my and partly it's a
critique of this idea that we can chop
and change bits of ourselves as though
our bodies are made of Lego which is
just obviously false um you know humans
you the human organism is an integrated
thing and you can't just you know add or
remove bits this is most we're seeing
this most commonly in this let's say the
right um but the but but the I've I've
I've drawn a I've drawn a link between
that and the Gnostic heresy which again
is a is is some there some lurks there
in the in the background of of the the
history of Christianity all the way all
the way from the I think from from the
early history really the the first
centuries the Gnostic heresy was like a
it was a what was it again it was was a
Greek some sort of they had a a
different God that wasn't the genealogy
of it is complic ated and people don't
entirely know because most most of the
most of the writings of the of the
Gnostic Cults were destroyed after the
after the alzan Crusade where they where
the Knights Templar just obliterated
them um so and I mean you know the may
you know some some of the gnostics may
have survived but but very little of
their paperwork does and most of what
people know about the gnostics um
survives in the records of um the
Inquisition so so and it's hard to say
it's it's hard to say you know how much
of what they what what was extra Ed
Under torture was you know by the
Spanish by the Inquisition was actually
accurate who knows um but I mean from
from from what we what we do know it has
it has some of its origins in Middle
Eastern deities but it's a it's it it's
an it's a manakan religion that you
there's a there's a good God and there's
an evil God and and the the entirety of
the material realm it was created by by
an evil demiurge to trap um our higher
spiritual Souls who who can only be
completed by escaping the material realm
to reunite with reunite with the with
the Divine um and and this is this is
sort of very very crude outline um and
and so so somewhere and I think there
are there are some clear differences
between this idea that we're that we're
disembodied selves um who who who ought
to be able to remodel our bodies as we
see fit which is the which is the sort
of fundamental premise of a lot of
gender ideology there are some
differences between that and and and the
and the Gnostic idea but the the sort of
core idea that there's something there's
something wicked or imprisoning about
the about the Physical Realm about or
about embodiment as such um has carried
has carried through direct from from
from the Gnostic heresy and I mean there
are there are those who those who make
the case that that the the sort of the
the flourishing of the flourishing of
science from Protestant from the
Protestant Reformation onwards you know
continued the Gnostic Gnostic tradition
I mean you know there are there are sort
of Arcane kind of you know history of
ideas
side quests you can follow yeah on this
topic if you want to you my my my my
late friend Wendy wheeler argues that
Francis Bacon was one of the one of the
most um influential modern gnostics how
so well in in that he he he de his his
no you know the the idea the scientific
method in a sense you in disenchanting
the material realm and rendering it an
object of study rather than a sort of
Enchanted domain a book A book written a
book of signs written by God you know in
in a sense that's that's a it it it
strips it strips the life and the
enchantment from the from from the
material realm in in ways which is not
dissimilar to you know dismissing
dismissing it as a sort of evil prison
um and it it argues that you know in as
much as it implies that that way of
looking at the world that in as much as
there's anything good or worthwhile
about people it's in the realm of idea
in the realm of rationality and that in
a sense our bodies are are an obstacle
to our becoming fully ourselves kind of
pessimistic view here because you don't
believe that there's political Solutions
you're pessimistic about the cultural
Solutions you think we're going into
Reformation which of course is followed
then by very bloody
wars no hesitation there um uh and it it
seems like only things are getting worse
is there a positive what can be done
that's positive
to uh get us out of this I think you
need I think you need to take the Long
View you know the the 100 Years War only
lasted 100 years yeah quite short I
guess you know we we might not live to
see the end of the of the the new
Reformation but somebody will you know I
don't think I don't think humanity is
toast far from it you know the L London
Will Survive modernity for example
because it's just too geographically
well placed for to be otherwise um you
know Humanity Will Survive modernity as
well you know in what form is anybody's
guess mhm um but if if if if as as is my
contention modernity
is in crisis and like and and we're past
Peak progress and perhaps we have a long
way to come down you know it doesn't
follow from that that that it's all over
see my my positive if I'm going to give
a positive answer to that Mary is that I
see a people going back to church and
noticeably unlike 20 years ago or 10
years ago it's less call to publicly
profess your Christianity I find that
very interesting yeah I noticed that
this month with Oliver Anthony the
singer coming out reading scripture on
Joe Rogan what that's like that's
unfathomable that someone would do that
before the num churchgoing numbers are
going up orbe it in certain churches and
not others and um it's almost like I
think there's a Martin gri line he says
something when people give up on the the
city of man they turn back to the city
of God and it seems to me that that is
the positive
I guess that's reformational in a sense
it is it is I mean I I think I I often
find myself thinking about you know the
the prognosis for for public
Christianity um I I I attend our we
attend our local Anglican Church which
is you know it's in the same doldrums as
most Anglican churches right you know
it's it's most of the congregation is is
pushing you know you there are there AR
there's not many members of the
congregation who are under 60 put it
that way um and and in that it's it's
just it has has that in common with you
a great many other churches and and I
was I was looking around and I was
thinking is it is it just over and and
actually I don't think so I mean I think
it may well be over for the Church of
England as a public political
institution in the form you know in the
in the role it's played in in Britain's
political system since the Glorious
Revolution I think and or really really
since since since Henry VII did what he
did you know that that that may well be
over um but but I don't think the
Christian faith is over
I I just don't because it's you know
it's it's had it's had years in the
wilderness before and here we here we
still are MH you know 2,000 years later
okay so uh um I'll I'll take that as
a there there are plenty plenty of other
reasons to be cheerful um I mean I've
I've I'm by no means by no means doomish
about about what we do next you know I
dedicated the whole last third of the
book to to things to to things that we
might do on on on a small scale on an
interpersonal scale to to to respond to
where we are now MH I mean I think which
is the which is reactionary feminism
which is yeah yeah re reactionary
feminism which started as a joke
actually it was a it was a long running
argument with via Twitter dm with a
friend or now a friend there was then
then a relative stranger who was this
this guy who wrote to me say you
shouldn't call yourself post- liberal
you should call yourself a reactionary
and I said what who are you and we had
this long argument about whether whether
whether reaction or was more useful than
post liberal it went on for months and
eventually eventually I was persuaded of
of his view which which was that
reactionary is better than post- liberal
so for people who don't know what
reactionary family is what's the
elevator pitch and they can get the rest
of it in the book what does it look like
if you if you set out to advocate for
women's interests but you don't believe
in
progress and you know the is is the
short you know the short answer to the
question well there isn't really a short
answer the the answer the the answer the
only answer I've been able to come up
with to the question if is about 50,000
words long and it is this book uh I
highly recommend the book I still think
it's a sort of conservative type of
feminism maybe that will I mean the the
difference between a conservative and a
reactionary this is I have to quote the
one of the greatest reactionary of all
times again at you on that which is
Nicolas Gomez Dava um who says you know
a reactionary will only become a
conservative in eras which in which
there's something worth conserving huh
so they think there's anything worth
conserving I don't think there's
anything much left to
conserve I mean you know pockets of
pockets of things which are worthwhile
are left but overall you I come into
London I think well you know there's
some some pretty buildings but even
those buildings are mostly now hollowed
out um by by hedge funds who who've
rebuilt who who' kept the facade and
rebuilt them on the inside with steel
girders
um which I think is just a perfect
metaphor for so much really so actually
it's kind of like an Anarchist
feminist well no no being a reaction and
being an anarchist are to you and
Anarchist just want to smash everything
um and and create everything from first
principles all the time which just feel
that's just exhausting I mean I've tried
living life from first principles all
the time it's really
tiring you know you need habits you need
you need habitual ways of doing things
because otherwise it's just crazy making
you never get anything done yeah you
have to you have to think about where
you put your pants you because you put
them somewhere different to where you
put them yesterday today is it yeah it's
just crazy making well on that note Mary
thank you so much for speaking with me
we uh went into quite a lot of the weeds
but um there's a there's a lot more
there and it's all actually very clear
in your um book which I have recommended
and given copies to many friends because
I think it's really brilant I'm really
excited about it and I'm uh excited
about what I see as a bit of a movement
with you and and Louise and and these
other writers because I think it's
really necessary and and and I I'm glad
that there are people thinking
positively about mothers and families um
uh which uh seems really important and
maybe that's the sort of start that we
need even if it there's no political
cultural answers just yet at least that
you're thinking about it and that's
phenomenal so um thank you so much for
speaking for me and is where can people
find you I mean we've already said
unheard in Spectators is there any any
any anywhere else that they can find you
online
I am I'm on Twitter at moving circles um
I have a I have a sporadic substack also
titled reactionary feminist wonderful
well Mary Harrington thank you so much
for speaking with
[Music]
me